do you have advice for other filmmakers
or even actors who were going through
that they've come off something that's
successful but as each day happens
within the 24 hour news feed their thing
gets buried more and more and more I
kind of understand what you're saying I
I'm dealing right now with because both
things have changed over the years the
way that you get feedback from people
and audience members critics etc it's
changed now it's all about social media
in the past you had to wait for printed
you know reviews etc now you're getting
during Q&A s you would find out what
people like now it's literally like I
get a tweet seconds after the movie you
know as soon as the lights came up in
the theater so I am you know I deal with
that a lot because I focus on the
negative reactions it's just something
that's my personality I I haven't even
there are some wonderful reviews and
people are telling haven't you you
haven't read that review it I'm like no
I'm focusing on the the rotten tomato
not the fresh tomato it's it's something
it's just masochistic or something but I
but and you're right though about the
way that things get the positivity might
get buried by suddenly a lot a load of
negative tweets but then the positive
ones come back so it's you got it I'm
starting to be able to cope but but what
can you do you're not going to please
anyone everyone and then on top of that
it's like I look at the films that I
love my favorite films and they've
divided audiences uh-huh you know 5050 I
mean there are some of my favorite films
people have walked out at or booed at it
can you know and so I can't concern
myself with pleasing every single person
and plus the subject matter that we're
normally covering with my films they
they fall along a political
viewpoints and if you're not and if
there are going to be plenty of people
there who don't agree with me
politically on some of these movies it's
just a simple fact and and so that will
divide people and it's something that I
can't get too concerned about them it's
just it's it's the way things are so
you